hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book nineteen of the City of God
Augustine is fundamentally concerned
with determining what the final end or
the supreme good for human beings would
be and he notes that there is a great
diversity of beliefs and opinions says
philosophers have expressed a variety of
these regarding the ends of goods and
evils and this question they have
eagerly canvassed so that they might if
possible discover what makes a human
being happy genuinely fulfilled and he
refers to Varro somebody who Augustine
brings up quite quite often
unfortunately we don't have the work
that he's referring to de philosophie
actually we don't have anything by Varro
that has survived antiquity and in that
book Varro sets out a classification for
all the different possible points of
view that philosophers either did have
or could have about how we ought to live
our life how we ought to orient
ourselves towards that which is
ultimately going to make us happy and he
comes up with 288 sects as it's being
called here of philosophers this term
sex we probably ought to dwell upon a
little bit because for many of us in the
present this term has the connotation of
a religious group that one would belong
to generally a smaller group that has
you know quite a tight membership and
some strong beliefs and doctrines and
discipline in earlier times the word
that we're actually translating here as
sex and Greek is hide races which comes
from the word hydrangea to grab or to
choose or to select and it was quite
common in ancient times both to talk
about philosophers and to talk about
religious people as belonging to a high
racist
to a sect and what did they mean by that
a choice of what was really fundamental
what oriented oneself whether it's one's
beliefs or one's actions or a
combination of the two and you can
understand philosophical movements and
schools and and you know ways of
approaching things what we call
perspectives has very much analogous to
those of religions of the time because
those had to do with how you lived your
life as well and the beliefs that you
you were following so how does he come
up with 288 philosophical sects there is
a process of multiplication that we can
go through so let's actually follow out
Vera's depiction of how this takes place
according to Augustine we can begin by
asking the question what is it that we
human beings really fundamentally desire
what what drives us and Varro
distinguishes four possibilities now of
course could we could we come up with
other possibilities on her own yes we
could we're not saying that he
necessarily covered the entire gamut
here but we don't need to worry about
whether he did or not let's just follow
out and see where this goes so one
possibility of what fundamentally
motivates us what would drives us is
pleasure
another possibility repose or rest or an
absence of pain an absence of trouble
another possibility would be both think
about the Epicureans for example who
weren't just pursuing pleasure but also
freedom from pain as well and who saw
the highest pleasures to reside in and
rest and then there's what he calls the
primary objects of nature and this was a
common classification if you read
through much ancient moral theory you
will see references to the this this
class and it includes everything from
you know our our bodies and and what
sustains them to these sort of basic
drives that go beyond that the pleasure
or rest thing and have to do with
fulfilling what our bodily nature is
about so we've got four things that we
could desire so so far so good now we
have another thing that human beings
recognize as desirable as valuable as
good and that's virtue moral virtue and
we can ask ourself the question do we in
fact desire virtue first of all for its
own account virtue and the virtues
specific modes of virtue or do we desire
it for the sake of something else right
do we desire virtue for pleasure or for
repose or rest be virtuous so we don't
run into problems or because it's it's
you know these primary objects of nature
that are driving us or do we desire
these things for the sake of pleasure or
are they going on two different tracks
where we desire pleasure or we desire
the primary objects of nature for their
own sake but we also desire virtue for
its own sake now we have 12 right we
have a greater number of possibilities
then we can ask a further question which
widens the scope from ourselves as
individuals to encompass other human
beings the things that we desire
whatever arrangement we happen to have
of these you know original desires and
then virtue are we desiring it for our
sake alone or are we designing it for
some companions as well those companions
could be friends they could be neighbors
they could be members of our family they
could be the entire world as such they
could be whoever happens to be in
relation to me but this is a division
that we can make and now we're
multiplying it yet further you can see
how quickly this category list is
expanding then he brings up the ancient
skeptic school the Academy of Plato's
Academy that is after Palomo before it
was redeveloped into a genuinely
platonic school
and we can say are you holding this
viewpoint as absolutely certain or are
you holding it as merely probable then
he brings up another philosophical
school and says okay so all of this
other stuff how are you going to live
this out are you going to live the mode
of the life of the cynics and what he
means by this is traveling around that
may be sort of fixed abode bagging
inviting yourself into things not having
any real participation in the normal
institutions of life although there was
a cynic who was too cynics of course who
were married hip Archaea and cara taste
right or are you gonna live like other
philosophers that is are you going to
have a bank account are you going to
have a house are you going to have a
fixed residence where you would reside
and notice how many different courses we
already have how many sex or hide races
then we can go on and ask yet another
question which gets us to the full
extent of this should you be involved in
an active life and an active life means
a life devoted to business devoted to
your country or your culture or your
city or perhaps even just your family a
life of as we say affairs or is it
better to live this out in a life of
study and contemplation removing
yourself from all of these other things
or should you live a mixed life that
combines these two that in some ways
determines when you ought to be active
and when you ought to be contemplative
what Zeno called as opposed to the
active life or the contemplative life
the rational life right so now we've got
this massive number of different
possibilities an Augustine goes on and
he says that Varro himself refuted all
of the rest of the sects and chose one
the old academy instituted by Plato
continuing on to Palermo
and he said that you know that was the
the group that he was going to select
now Augustine is going to bring up
something else that in some ways makes
all of these distinctions less useful he
says that a genuine sect a genuine hate
race is a genuine choice fundamental
choice about how you orient yourself
it's only gonna differ from the other
schools about the supreme or the final
good but most of these other things in
here like whether you live like a cynic
or whether you regard it as merely
probable most of those things have to do
with how we orient ourselves towards the
final good they don't tell us what the
final good itself is so we actually
could get rid of many of these
distinctions and we would be quite fine
so Varro himself says let's look at it
in terms of what a human being is and so
we could think of it in terms of body
and soul the human being is a composite
of body and soul so we might think in
terms of the good of the body right the
primary objects of nature because he
actually ends up rolling pleasure repose
both into the primary objects of nature
he simplifies it a bit or we can think
of the good of the soul which is virtue
no longer just pleasure or something
like that the actual moral rectitude
rightness the sort of habits that make
us a good person then we could also
think about it in terms of the good of
the body combined with the good of the
soul and you know this allows us to say
that here we go it's neither the soul
alone or the body alone both together
the body and soul each being a part so
of these Varro chooses the third that
the human being
is both together therefore the highest
good in which lies the happiness of
human beings is composed of goods of
both kind both bodily and spiritual so
that the primary objects of nature
whatever those happen to be would be
among the goods that comprise the final
end or final good and moral virtue so
you're rolling two things in together as
a kind of composite of what the good for
human beings look like now Augustine
himself is going to reject this
and say that the good the supreme good
for human beings the final end cannot
lie in any of these things but he is
following Varro's analysis up to the
point where he is going to make that
very important distinction that takes
him beyond this classification that he
spends several chapters at the beginning
of book 19 unpacking so now you can see
what he's doing with this as well as
what all of these seemingly innumerable
distinctions and opposition's actually
amount to
you